so next we're going to talk about
money
now obviously like money is important to
all of us here it's the way that we feed
our families
um but i'm used to money a little
different than
where you guys are starting to
to get used to money looking ahead at
the next 25 years
let's talk about
this cryptocurrency
we're going to look at tyrese first
we know we talk about nfts when we talk
about this world
you're the first name that come up
tyrese tell us how you got involved in
this space and teach me something man i
don't i don't know a lot of knowledge my
older brother tanner uh he told me about
nba top shot and he was like it's
basically virtual trading cards and i
kind of blew him off i'm like bro that
sounds terrible like i like physical
things you know right
and then i was born in my hotel room was
in chicago and i tweeted something like
dang i i missed the boat on top shot
like my moment went up five dollars or
whatever went to team meet and came back
it was up like 50. i was like
i was like
then from there i became obsessed with
this stuff nba top shot was a
substantial catalyst to why nfts are
popular today i'm gary vaynerchuk i'm
the ceo of vaynerx and an entrepreneur
it was incredibly commercially
successful dapper labs and with rohan
leading did a phenomenal job with that
product and really captivated the sports
card collecting community to get excited
about nfts in a frictionless way the
reason people are struggling with nfts
is because it's truly a profound new
technology nfts stand for non-fungible
tokens and we're all bringing our
internet brain to the blockchain the
blockchain is a new technology
decentralized servers nobody controls
them nobody owns them what that allows
for is the ability to show ownership of
something that's digital
somebody may say why does somebody want
to do that but we do that all the time
now uh when you think about nba 2k and
you're buying some plus ups for your
players you own that now digitally and
when you put the video game in and
you're playing 2k 2k knows that and
you're happy because you have a better
team or something or you're wearing
cooler clothes but that's just in a
closed environment
the blockchain is the whole world the
way the internet's the whole world so
someone like me who don't know a lot
about it in my mind you just have to get
lucky like is it a science to picking
nfts is it like tell me how do i go and
find and pick nfts so there's probably
tens of thousands of nfts that release
on a daily basis and
probably like five of them are actually
gonna hit what does hit like me as in
like an nf team like
like how much do you have to do to get
into it like do you buy like a certain
amount well i mean it just depends on
like the collection you like right so
like if you really like something you
can buy multiple of it and if you get in
early enough and you want to put a
certain amount of bread into it go ahead
but like i'll show you like my biggest
energy success story is board ape uh i
was getting tagged on twitter to buy
this because people knew i was big in
topshop so i bought it for two ethereum
at the time which was four grand two or
what two ethereum which is four grand
that's the cth
and now it's the minimum price for one
board eight there's a hundred e it's
like three hundred
i put it on my kicks we played the
pelicans yeah i bought it like kicks and
that blew up the reason nfts are going
to work is they work more like fashion
than they do like wall street the nba
player today sits at the tippy top along
with popular hip-hop artists and
influencers on tiktok as the most
influential cultural beasts in our
society when these players change their
avatars uh people are going to follow
they're going to get excited
what's lucky
for the nft space which is why i'm very
bullish in a 25-year window is even in
the first year there's less hysteria
around that one year ago any nba player
not even an all-star
changing an avatar to any nft project
made the project move aggressively
luckily people realized that's not a
great way to think about betting on a
project which is phenomenal because
almost always when you would see that
unless a hundred other people in culture
did the same thing you you're gonna see
a downtrend you hate to see athletes
come in and like they call like pump and
dump where like you you buy an nft you
tweet about it so it blows up and then
you just sell it to make quick cash
that's where athletes mess up people do
that all the time and then your
reputation in the community goes down
and then people don't care if you get in
it you know what i'm saying you got to
be as genuine as possible because then
you'll get a lot of love and when the
next nft comes out people are going to
give you the tip on that and then you
can just keep going from there and keep
making more money and help make
everybody else money so that's the
biggest thing is just the community that
gets behind it as long as you're
authentic and real about it it's good
the problem
with the word community in nft space
right now is that almost everyone in the
community is full of crap
it's not a real community it's not like
a being a knicks fan now what you have
is 95 of people day trading and the
community where it is being thrown up as
a disguise for people having short-term
financial interest
it depends on two like what nfts you buy
like i bought an nft and i tweeted it
and then immediately people are like
posting the nfts that they have the same
one like people are following me on
different social medias like i'm in the
discord they're like messaging on that
it's like right away they kind of like
bring you into that community you do
kind of have to get lucky like that's so
awesome you have a board ape like but
you don't know which one's gonna hit
yeah and world of women have kind of
picked up speed when i got one and i
just really liked like what the brand
represented that's kind of what it is
too like you see something you like you
research it i like what they represented
it's like women owned
they do like a lot of stuff for abused
women things like that and the art is
really cool so i really liked it and i
bought it and now the four is going up
so i mean hopefully it turns into board
apes i'm trying to be like you
i think i think you mentioned a great
point too that we did talk about like
nfts with like utility that stuff
matters it's like some of them they just
do it to release to make the money but
like the ones that are continuing to do
well they do other things like worlds of
women i get other stuff because i bought
that one yes like you get other stuff
like those are the ones that you should
watch out for because those are ones
that are going to do well right now
everyone's focused on it has
collectibility but there's a smart
contract and there's some utility that
you can do with that
i predict in 25 years everybody will
realize nfts really were utility with a
hint of collectibility can this be an
nft moment right here like someone can
buy nft to have a seat at this table
right now all-star weekend that could be
the utility but it's gonna be one of the
utilities yes you could create you
create your own utility through
everything garyvee just dropped a fly
fish do you have one of those yeah no i
don't have one
so you have to buy an nft and he has a
restaurant you can only get in the
restaurant if you have that in there
yeah unlike a country club or the soho
house or things of that nature it's an
asset
it's not like you're paying a membership
fee every year and that lets you in and
fine no no this is you own the pass and
let's say on thursday you went and you
were there the 19th time and you've had
enough of us you like literally can list
it so this space this this
cryptocurrency these nfts this metaverse
this entire world that we all are being
introduced to
you say it's real
is it real enough that we're going to be
taking our salaries in crypto i asked
for but they said no we can't do it but
i did ask for it really then somebody
like oh i think odell tried to get his
uh salary i think he did that
he did he did and then it went down it
was like a big yeah but it'll come back
up it's all volatile right like yeah but
i think
me personally i'd rather just get it in
cash
but my biggest reason is if you want to
turn it into crypto which is cool to me
yeah like you know it's volatile right
so if all these all of our organizations
are going to do is take our cash and buy
ethereum at a random time for a certain
amount but if we get it in cash and we
know we want to use it as soon as it
falls then we can buy it we can get more
for ourselves you know what i'm saying
so me personally i was just i was i'm
cool with just cash you're cool with
cash i'm cash's kick all right but you
want to joe as in currency yeah just
because it's like such a new thing and
like such a new wave and it's just kind
of like um what you were saying just
being immersed in like the community and
bringing awareness it was kind of more
for that like that is absolutely true my
reasoning was just like to bring more
awareness and kind of like get the way
of higher we know that our games are
built on
the fans that's in a building
how's the experience changed with nfts
does it become the tickets to get into
the game or you know season ticket
holders get nft like what is the
experience for our fans in the next
you know 25 years how does this grow how
does this evolve i think you'll
definitely see it in tickets i think
they'll be buying tickets and like
ethereum or different cryptocurrencies
one thing i guarantee you about the nba
in 25 years is that our tickets are nfts
and i don't tell anybody who's watching
this you can go to ebay right now search
mba tickets things sell but
the mba didn't make any royalties on
that transaction the reason the mba will
issue nft tickets is when that special
night happens and it becomes collectible
as people are walking out of madison
square garden hopefully it's a nick out
of madison square garden and they are
literally listing or taking so you don't
have to list them blockchain like
they're taking offers on that nft
because it sits on the blockchain and
are literally hitting accept as they're
going down the escalators and making
money because they picked the right
night to go to the garden that is
profound it's also profound because when
i buy that ticket because i'm in la
watching and i'm excited that rj barrett
jr dropped 100 points in an nba game and
i need that collectible i may sit on
that for five years and when rj barrett
jr goes to the hall of fame in 22 years
that ticket might be worth even more and
i may sell that when i sell that for a
profit the nba is going to make a
royalty and every time that's ticket is
sold in perpetuity
the mba is incentivized to turn every
ticket into an nft versus a qr code the
fans that go to these games are
incentivized to have it to be an nft
versus qr code because they can sell it
this is
a profoundly exciting moment that most
people don't see yet when you buy the
nft it feels like you have a part of
that athlete like you own this moment
forever you know so i feel like it
creates that fan engagement where they
feel like they're even more apart that's
what fans want like yes they love
watching us on the court but they love
to feel like they're part of our lives
right so owning a moment like of your
playing career is huge so i think it's
just going to get bigger
i guess the biggest question would
everyone wants to know is nfts here to
stay or is it just
for now i feel like it's where you guys
like it's like the new wave right now
yeah but i think it's i think it's here
to stay because i think that's the
future of our world we're not going to
like print out prints of family photos
and hang it on our walls like i think
people will do that but i see the future
as like
big ipads on our walls that cycle
through family photos and cycle through
nfts and art and all these different
things and on people's desks when you
walk in they'll have little frames with
nfts on it you know what i'm saying i
see that as the future of the world and
i can't remember who said this but they
said it was like when the internet first
came out like there were so many
different things but like if you got
into the good ones like google amazon
like those hit big so like the nfts like
a lot of them won't but the big ones
like they're gonna hit really big and
they're here to stay this is the best
part though like like when we ask each
other questions about it you know what
i'm saying like that's i think is the
best part is that guys who were maybe
afraid to ask me questions about what
nfts are aren't anymore a lot of the nba
players have been very aggressive with
nft land because i think nba players
are by nature the most entrepreneurial
the most creative the most technically
like there's it's just the energy of the
league the days of players being
incredibly one-dimensional is long long
gone the thoughtfulness is profound
these players are making a lot of money
now on the court given the great success
of the league and they're being
thoughtful they want to put those
dollars to work in the right ways one of
the things i'm most excited about is the
first couple meaningful projects done by
an nba player
that isn't specifically in the concept
of their name and jersey within it
things that they're doing from the
outside and i think you're gonna see
that and it's gonna happen and when it
happens it's going to create a ripple
within the league that is going to
inspire other guys in the league to do
thoughtful projects around their
interests which i think leads to a
better nba player i have empathy that
owners and gm's may be scared about what
guys are doing i've analyzed with my
ambitions to once one day on the new
york jets i've been analyzing guys for a
long time and i think a more rounded
player is a better performer on the
court and so i'm excited about that
chapter
everybody is like at first it's like
i don't know what i'm saying i'm not
with that but like even my mom and dad
like they're like okay i'm trying to get
into that now you know what i'm saying
nfc was good i learned some stuff today
we need it we need to talk